hey everyone and welcome to today's hd
tutorial and in this one i'll be showing
you how to get and install the safari 4
beta on your mac or your pc so right now
i'm going to open up safari just to show
you guys that i currently have the
version of safari you may be using so go
to help about safari and it'll tell you
i have version 3.2.2 now you see i have
a lot of favorites right here and a lot
of bookmark pages that i actually want
to keep if i want to go back to these
for further reference so what i want to
do
is to actually just upgrade my version
of safari so i'm going to go to
www.apple.com
go to the downloads tab of their website
and down here you will see safari 4.0
beta for mac or pc is a 31 megabyte
download if it is not here just go to
their search box and type in safari and
the first one will be safari 4. so just
go ahead and click on the safari icon
and it will come up with the new safari
4 beta
so here on this website we're going to
say we're going to click safari for
windows xp or vista okay i'm going to
uncheck this because i don't want to put
in my email just hit that download now
button and make sure your pc meets the
minimum requirements are going to do is
hit open and it'll first start
downloading the new version of safari 4
beta now it says it's going it's a
little bit of a slow download right now
but it's a 25 megabyte initial download
and it'll take approximately 30
megabytes on your hard disk now what i'm
going to show you while it's downloading
is that it's going to look a lot more
strikingly like google chrome in that
the tabs are on the top here we're going
to have rss button the refresh we're
going to have browsing using cover flow
okay full full page previews of your
bookmarks and getting to know your top
sites so you know i'm just going to come
back to you guys when the safari 4 beta
is done downloading
all right here i've resumed the video
and we see that the cam cam ah sorry the
safari setup.exe
has been finished downloading so we're
going to run the file that's all i did
was go downstairs and come back and
resume the video so just hit the run
button
and it'll bring us into the installer
which i believe will ask us for the
language first hold on
and while this is actually starting i'm
just going to exit out of the safari 3
which is probably going to be necessary
for installing sephora safari 4 anyway
so let's wait for safari 3 safari 4 here
it says safari is the fastest and most
innovative web browser for mac and pc
and we already saw that there's going to
be a ton of changes so we're going to
hit next
we have to agree to the service and
license license agreement and everything
hit the accept button and hit next
and here i'm going to install a desktop
shortcut because i'm going to eventually
drag into my rocket dock to replace this
safari and we're going to hit install
now since we did not change the actual
location of where it's going to install
it's going to detect by itself as we
follow apple's instructions here that
it's actually detecting our previous
version of safari in that folder it's
going to remove that but keep all of our
favorites preferences our auto fill and
all that customizable stuff um actually
still in safari as we um we prepare for
installation here so says please please
wait while safari installs and this may
take several minutes so i'll come back
to you guys when this is finished um
finished with this particular step
all right we're come back and we're
we've come back here to the final step
as removing the old favorites and
applications and replacing them with the
same exact information but in the newer
file format for safari for so it's
finishing the installation of safari and
if we scroll up here you'll see that
it's already put an icon on my desktop a
little shortcut
for me to drag actually into my rocket
dock in the first place so now we see
it's validating the install so let's
just wait until safari has finished
installing the application and then
we'll go into and show you a little bit
of the the new things that have actually
been incorporated into safari for so
just wait one second
all right when you've finished
installing it says congratulations
safari has been
successfully installed
and i'm going to
uncheck open safari after it exits and
i'm just going to hit the finish button
here in that new window now in order to
do this to drag into my rocket dock i'm
just going to right click on the dock
and unlock items here
drag out the old safari icon and it just
disappears take the new safari icon drag
it in
to where i want it let go and then i'm
going to lock it again now you'll see
the old one is still here since this is
just a shortcut it'll obviously tell us
this is just a shortcut and i'll say yes
remove it so now we have the new safari
4.0 beta and i'm just going to click on
it to open it let's see if it's any
faster or slower that's pretty fast and
right off the bat i'm noticing that's a
completely new theme here it's using the
windows arrow of course i i made to do
that in my old version of safari but the
first boot of safari is going to be
totally different first thing i'm going
to point out is that up here there's a
little bug button where you can um
report the bugs and here we have a
little introduction saying welcome to
safari four
and here are our top sites just like
google chrome it has the top sites we
have visited
almost like and it seems to be loading
the top sites that i've already visited
which is pretty cool
so this is um a lot reminiscent of
google chrome first of all the fact that
you can add a new tab just by hitting
that plus button
second of all the fact that it has all
your top sites here and it's actually
pretty accurate this is my home page
this is apple.com it's going to load and
here's all my old favorites which is
very cool have my website uh the project
that i'm doing it still has all of my
bookmarks and that's a pretty cool new
theme and i think i like that
so now it's finishing and it says it's
gonna be a lot like cover flow here as
safari 4 incorporates cover flow so i'm
just going to hit that button to open a
new tab that's pretty cool one more tab
so it seems to just um load this exact
page every time it opens a new tab and
there you go for you that's my head top
sites if i just click on it it'll like
come to the front and it loads extremely
quick almost as if it's in the cachet
already
so that's a pretty cool graphic that
they've shown us
so second in safari um in the new safari
4 beta what you can actually do here
is if i hit this button we can browse in
cover flow mode so if i were to go to
google.com
actually that didn't work i didn't type
that correctly
so let's go to
google.com
and what i'm going to do is add it as a
favorite and it says are you sure you
want oh yes i do
so instead of rolling scrolling in from
the top it actually opens a new window
which is pretty interesting that i can
obviously choose where i want to save
that bookmark and it'll put it in up
here so i'm going to hit cancel because
i already have my bookmarks and this it
says show top sites all i have to do is
click that and it automatically brings
up this window again that's pretty cool
if i hit the home button yes it keeps my
home page it keeps my google home page
change a little bit of the buttons but
that's all right and if i go to email
here i can obviously i'm not email if i
go to bookmarks i can scroll my
bookmarks in cover flow that's a big
change in safari 4 that that cover flow
integration into windows as well as pcs
so that's very cool that you can do that
in safari 4. just click it again to get
out of bookmarks and we're back
and that's basically it guys all the
options remain the same you still have a
lot of that um that reminiscent of
what you call google chrome that you can
you have all your options over here
instead of on the left you don't
actually have a file
new thing because if i want to go to new
tab all i have to do is hit that new tab
button so you also have the options you
have show menu bar or hide it show or
hide bookmarks bar status bar and also
you may have noticed when i was loading
the page if i were to load
a larger page here and that's cool that
it has a top site and bookmarks so
youtube.com you'll see it doesn't load
it has a little swirly thingy here
instead of actually loading up here
so i'm gonna get back to you guys on
more add-ons and bookmarks let's see if
i hit sign in if it remembers yes it
does remember so it still has all the
auto fill
so yeah i'm gonna get back to you guys
on more plug-ins and add-ons for safari
and more uh little bugs that i can
report to you guys but that's basically
it so thanks for watching this video and
i hope that you found it helpful and
good luck with installing safari for on
your brand new computer or just on your
computer so thanks for watching this
video if you have any other tutorial
ideas or requests just go ahead and
subscribe and send me a message and i'll
get back to you in a response thanks for
watching peace